new numbers show legal marijuana sales
in Massachusetts are booming the states
- pot shops reported more than 2.2
million dollars of sales during their
first five days of business they've sold
more than 56,000 marijuana products
since tonita copal is inside a
dispensary in leicester massachusetts
with how the bustling pot business is
causing unexpected friction Tony good
morning good morning bustling indeed by
law and by custom legal marijuana shops
try to keep a low profile but here at
cultivate demand has been so strong
they've actually had to put in airport
style line dividers and residents say no
matter how controlled or subdued it may
seem in here it's been out of control
outside and they're letting public
officials hear about that at an
emergency town meeting tensions were
high Monday night in Leicester as
residents fumed about how the success of
the marijuana shop cultivate has turned
their quiet neighborhood into a busy
shopping hub it took me 20 minutes get
out of my driveway today alone we did
not anticipate the thousands of vehicles
that come here on a daily basis
Lester's Police Chief James Hurley says
customers can wait for hours and lines
that sometimes wrap around the block
also getting what I call cannabis
tourism and there are hundreds of people
who are just coming out to see what's
going on and that adds pressure to the
system representatives of cultivate say
they are working to address the concerns
of the community adding for instance
eighty more parking spaces and extra
police detail to keep traffic moving the
store served about a thousand customers
on opening day according to the cannabis
Control Commission the Friday after
Thanksgiving was the busiest for both
locations in the state reporting nearly
four hundred and eighty thousand dollars
in gross sales I'm not saying this is
gonna be a cure-all solution but this is
what it's a small town like Leicester
needs some residents like John Shoshu
came to show support for the financial
benefits cultivate may offer this small
town of 11,000 residents the guy is
overly successful we want to punish
that and I'm sorry it's just not the
American ways well one thing residents
are apt to appreciate is the tax revenue
this is an eighth of marijuana it's
about $60 an ounce of marijuana would be
four hundred and twenty dollars and no
matter what the some about a fifth
twenty percent goes to the tax bottom
line so when you hear that 2.2 million
number for early revenue just think
one-fifth is going not to the businesses
but to residents of the state of
Massachusetts Nora that is part of the
incentive indeed Tony thank you so much